Here are the correct answers. Great work if you got those correct. For the
first one we simply multiply the radicants together to get the square root of
25. We know the square root of 25 equals 5. For the second one we really have 5
times 5, since the square root of 25 equals 5. We know 5 times 5 equals 25, our
final answer. Another way to do this problem would be to multiply these two
radicants together to get 625. So really we're taking the square root of 625 or
25 squared. Notice that whenever you multiply a radical by itself, you just get
whatever was underneath it in the first place, just 25. Now this is only true
for square roots, it won't be true for high order roots. To start multiplying
the third one, we want to multiply the numbers on the outside together first.
So we'll have 5 times 5 on the outside and then the square root of 25 here. We
know 5 times 5 equals 25 and we know the square root of 25 equals 5. We
multiply one last time to get 125. This is the simplification for the fourth
one, and we really just want to break down the 50 into a perfect square. We
take the square root of 25, which equals 5, and then multiply these two numbers
together to get 25 root 2. And finally for our last one, 2 times 12 equals 24.
And then we multiply the cube roots together to get the cube root of 24, that's
this 12 times 2. We split up 24 into 8 times 3 so that we can take the cube
root of 8, which equals 2. We multiply one last time to get 48 times the cube
root of 3. Nice effort on these problems.